when you're trying to save money you
often think of cutting out the big stuff
but constantly buying disposable items
can add up to some major cash
so today i'm going to show you 25 things
that you may have around your home
that have a reusable option that you can
swap out for to save money
i've included the link in the
description to most of the items that i
will mention
but some of them are not in there
because i personally don't own them or i
don't know a lot about them to be able
to recommend them so if it's not there
that's why so let's just get started the
first area that i want to mention is
cleaning supplies and home maintenance
item number one is rechargeable
batteries if you have a lot of battery
operated items in your home
try to find rechargeable batteries and a
charger
we don't have a whole lot except for our
security cameras because we don't have a
lot of battery operated items
but if you do this can save you not only
money but the environment as well
item number two is reusable mop pads
if you have a mop like this kind for
hardwood floors or
laminate flooring then invest in
reusable mop covers
we bought one that had two just two
little mop pads
and i basically just throw it in the
washing machine and it comes out
nice and clean and i reuse it again i
got tired of buying those disposables
time and time again item number three is
wall
dryer balls i can't juggle these little
bad boys replace your dryer sheets
i used to have dryer sheets all the time
and i bought these i don't know maybe
two and a half years ago
and they basically live in the washing
machine except for when my toddler gets
a hold of them
and they help dry up your clothes a lot
faster by bouncing around through your
clothes and absorbing the moisture
the ones that i bought and a lot of them
that are sold online
come in a little mesh baggie and i just
basically repurposed this for something
else
and then these little guys live in the
dryer the next item on the list is
reusable grocery and mesh bags
depending on where you live this may or
may not save you money i know that
certain places do charge money for
grocery bags
here where i live it doesn't really save
me any money but it saves the
environment
i have basically one big bag where i
keep all of my other smaller bags
and then my mesh grocery bags and moving
on to
kitchen items item number five
is a reusable or washable dish sponge
i didn't know that these little bad boys
existed actually until about two years
ago
what we did is we bought a set of these
dish sponges that have a rough side and
then a soft side it's basically cloth
what we do is we throw it in the wash
when we do laundry and it comes out good
as new
we've had this almost yeah two years now
item number six on the list is a
silicone baking mat
i bought this about a year ago to
replace our parchment paper
but it's basically stick proof i've
actually burnt sweet potato on it
and it has come off very easily but
word of the wise wait until your pizza
cools and remove it
before cutting it i'm not the best chef
item number seven is one that i don't
have because i've just never really
found a need for personally
but it is cloth cling wrap it is
basically
beeswax covers and if you haven't heard
of this before
it's basically a cloth that has beeswax
on one side
and it covers your container and it
wraps around it just like cling wrap
would
now not only does this replace your
cling wrap and it is a reusable option
but it can actually save your family
from harmful chemicals because
cling wrap actually leeches on chemicals
to your food
so this might be an option to consider
if you want to replace your cling wrap
next up on the list is silicone storage
bags i bought a set of these little guys
a couple years ago
and i have put in dry things and also
stuff that's kind of sort of wet like
mango and it has done fine and it's not
leaked
this replaces my ziploc bags i have not
needed to purchase any more not only
that but it also saves space because
they're rather thin
but another word of wisdom is i once
wanted to have a fresh apple so i put my
apple and i put a knife in here
yeah who knew that a knife would
puncture a hole through this thing so
just don't put sharp things inside item
number nine on the list is
cloth napkins if you really take into
consideration
how much you spend on napkins and paper
products this can add up to
a lot so investing in a good set of
cloth napkins might really be a good
option for you
not only that but it also saves space
because of these big bulky boxes or
napkins and paper towels item number 10
on the list is reusable cups and mugs
the main thing i want to say on this is
use whatever product you like
but you will save money if you use
something reusable instead of just
constantly buying coffee cups
coffee mugs or using disposable water
bottles for me though i am a huge fan of
yeti
so we have a not so minimal yeti
collection and my husband actually is
using a coffee cup right now
but i found these huge lifesavers
because it's the only brand that i've
found
that has actually kept things cold or
warm all day long
my husband works in construction and i
see patients in their home
so for us this is a big deal because we
don't have a microwave
or refrigerator wherever we're working
this one personally
was a huge help too when i was bottle
feeding my little one because i could
keep her
her um water cold so when i would prep
her bottles
and then these two we used to take to
work
and of course coffee you gotta have
coffee so temperature maintenance might
not be a huge deal for you yeti is
actually pretty hefty in price
so just invest in a reusable water
bottle that you like that works for you
and on the note of beverages you can
save a lot of money by investing in
a water filter instead of constantly
buying cases of water
after a great deal of research we bought
the berkey filter because
it has fluoride filters available and
the filters last for several years and
it's also one that we can use on
rainwater creek water
we can just grab water from anywhere
place it on the top and we're good to go
berkey is another one of those products
that is a bit hefty in price so you
won't see savings for a while
but there are other products as well
such as ones that attach to your faucet
and some people just plain drink tap
water now i don't really particularly
trust my water supply but if you do then
have at it that's free
well almost i guess you still get a bill
right
number 12 on the list is reusable coffee
filters
we actually don't have any of these
because we just use a pot and some water
you want some but you can save a whole
lot of money if you do still have a
coffee maker and you do want to use
reusables there are
those options and i know that the k-cups
also have a reusable option as well so
you can look into that
item number 13 is reusable straws these
are a common eco-friendly alternative
but i don't know for me i just don't
find them necessary i can just drink
from the bottle
but there are stainless steel options
bamboo options
silicone options there's a lot of
different options out there for you
and let's move on to personal care items
item number 14 is a bamboo shower brush
we invested in one of these several
years ago because i just
hated constantly buying loofahs they
just fall apart all over you you have to
buy them repeatedly
and these make a darn good back
scratcher
item number 15 is not one that i ever
see myself using but i wanted to include
this on the list in case
you might like it and this is reusable
toilet paper
yeah i've worked a little too close with
bowel movements as an icu nurse
and as a mom i'm good that is not for me
but if this is for you
go right on ahead item number 16 is
again one that i don't have because i
don't find a need for it and it is
reusable face wipes now if you are
into buying face wipes one thing i would
recommend is that you buy a darker color
because some makeup does stain
and another tip if you want to just
avoid using face wipes is
coconut oil is great for removing makeup
you just smear it all over your face
wipe it off even oil resistant or what
is it called
waterproof makeup you just wipe it off
and wash your faces normally it works
for me
item number 17 is a reusable safety
razor or an electric shaver
i know that a lot of people swear by the
safety razors for me
i have eczema my skin cannot go anywhere
near a
razor because my skin will get angry so
we've just had a reusable rechargeable
option
again find whatever works for you and
next up is
feminine care number 18 on the list is
reusable cloth
pads i purchased these several years ago
i have a regular size and then an
overnight size
and i actually did not buy them because
i was trying to save money but because i
found out
that pads disposable pads have chemicals
in them that can cause cancer
which i'm not into so i bought these
cloth pads and they come in this
little pouch which is very discreet and
they unbutton
and i have used these a lot i don't
really use them anymore
um but they never stained i just throw
them in the washing machine
and done good as new i later
after finding out about cloth pads
switch to a menstrual cup
and originally i started with a luna cup
which worked just fine for me
but i switched to the lily cup compact
just because it's so compact it's so
small it fits in this little container
that fits in my wallet or pocket
anywhere basically and it pops up
it is so soft so bendable i did not have
any issues with using this the first
time
but i have had a child so it might be
different for you i know that some
people
that have used a menstrual cup for the
first time have said that there's a
learning curve
so everybody's different there are lots
of different options out there but i
love
this one it's so soft and you don't ever
have to worry about
i ran out of tampons and you have to
either run to the store or send somebody
for some
not a problem anymore item number 20 is
panty liners i don't really use these
anymore but i use them near the end of
my first pregnancy
when i was paranoid about when my water
would break or paranoid postpartum about
when would my period come back but these
are similar to
the clock pads they have little snaps on
the back
that can be adjusted they have two
adjustables so that you can just place
them on
your underwear and toss in the washing
machine and
ready to use and last but definitely not
least is
baby products and i say hands down this
is the department where we have probably
saved
thousands disposable baby products can
get very hefty in price
so number 21 of course i have to mention
the number one money saver
for us reusable diapers we bought
these and spent about 500 to 600
when my baby was about one month old
almost and i am so glad that we did
they have adjustable snaps so we've been
able to use them from
birth well almost birth till now that
she is two
and i like these particular kind because
they are an all-in-one
meaning you don't have any um inserts
for them it's
all in one little package ready to go
and they have these little dividers so
you can fold them
for example right now i am expecting a
boy
so now i can fold this
so that it has more padding on one side
versus the other side
and also i just like it has adjustable
snaps
that it has the elastic on the sides and
the back
so the legs also are nice and cushioned
we had maybe a couple of leaves or
explosions but that was when she had
like some major diarrhea
other than that i have not had any
issues with these
and considering the average cost to
diaper one child is about two thousand
four hundred dollars
i would say that we have saved thousands
in the long run not only with the first
child but because i can reuse these for
kids to come
so we have the bum genius brand we
bought these at target but there are
lots of other brands i would say
look for whatever suits you what kinds
of stuff you like i
did a lot of research before buying
these and i bought only
this brand because i didn't want a whole
lot of different options that either i
liked or disliked i bought one tried it
out and liked it
but i would recommend that if this is
your first child or you plan to have
more children
then buy a color that you wouldn't mind
for your other kids to wear
and on the note of all of this a couple
tips that i would have for you if you
are planning two cloth diaper and you
don't know what to do
is i would suggest investing in a bidet
sprayer because
all i do is i basically grab the dirty
diaper
by the top side i spray it with the
bidet and throw it in the washing
machine
or i know that other people what they do
is they rinse them out outside on the
hose
throw it in a bucket and then once it's
full throw it all in the washing machine
and done there's lots of different
options for you do some research you
might be surprised it's not as daunting
as you might think
number 21 on the list is reusable baby
wipes
i didn't actually use this with my first
child i hadn't really heard about it
so this is something new that i'm going
to try out but i would
recommend that if you're going to do
this to do your research because there's
different kinds of solutions that you
can use
certain things that can be irritating to
your baby's skin and also you don't want
to harbor bacteria too if they're wet
constantly so
look into it before you actually do it
but this is an option that can save you
a lot of money in the long run
as well number 22 on the list is a wet
bag
this is actually something that i had
from a beach bag from a long time ago
but now i need more because i'm
expecting another one and i love
this because even with my toddler now
that i don't really
need to take diapers with her everywhere
that we go is
i can keep clean clothes in here and
then
if we happen to go to the park and she
gets messy or she gets wet somewhere
i can just stick the white clothes in
here and have an extra change of clothes
so this for me has been a huge lifesaver
number 24 on the list is reusable
nursing pads
when i was nursing my first i hated
these little disposable ones i have this
one as a freebie but i don't like it
because you have these all this plastic
that you have the tabs on and they get
hefty in price too so i just chunked
this and
invested in reusables and i bought this
little pouch that i think comes with a
set of eight
and i just throw it in the washing
machine they're soft they're comfortable
and they save me a lot of money but
another tip that i have for you is if
you want to save money but you don't
have the budget to buy some
is you can just use an old towel or
cloth or something that you have that's
soft
and absorbent cut little circles out of
them this is this is just for
demonstration purposes
because it's not sewn well well it's not
even sewn
but you can sew around the edges and
make your own if you can
if not you don't mind this then you can
just cut a towel and
use it with the fuzzies number 25 on the
list is silicone breast milk storage
bags
i did breastfeed my first child for a
while and i don't know how many hundreds
i must have spent on these disposable
plastic baggies
so i'm excited that now i found out
there is a reusable option for them it's
basically silicone bags
like my ziplocs that i showed you that
you reuse
wash put them in the freezer and you can
continuously use them again
so there you have it that is my 25
reusable items that can save you money
and as a bonus
save the environment as well as always
if you have any questions
or any suggestions of your own please
leave them in the comments so we can all
learn from each other
i so hope this video was helpful for you
if you liked it please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so you won't miss out
on my other videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to see you in the next one